- Do what I love.
- Choose something that you love to do.
- I really love what I'm doing.
- This is what I want to do.
- Hello Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk
about how to love what you do.
And as always, guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you see something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And if you write it down,
it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well.
(inspirational music)
- I'm a very spiritual person,
and I follow my spirit.
And I do what my spirit
tells me to do, you know.
And I don't have a set,
like, "Oh, I want to play
this type of character
"and I won't play that type of character."
I'm receptive to anything, you know.
And when the right thing comes along,
if it's serious, if it's
funny, if it's silly,
if it's low budget.
Put it this way, I just
do whatever makes me,
I get the most gratification
from as an artist.
I do music albums and
nobody buys my records.
I do them because I love
making music, you know.
And that's the same way I am about movies.
I don't make movies because,
I don't go into it
thinking, "Let me do this
"because then people will come."
"How much will the movie make?"
"I'm trying to make the audience do that."
I do what feels right for me.
- What were you like as a child?
- I was a combination of
reclusive and obsessed
with what I wanted to do.
When I was two, I was
sitting in front of the TV
drawing Fred Flintstones
and Woody Woodpeckers.
And at age seven I'm running around
like a crazy person doing voices.
But at the same time, I would
try to make animated films,
and try to figure out exactly
how that art form worked.
- When did you do your first cartoon?
How old were you and what was it?
- I was in seventh grade.
It was called Space
Pirates, it was terrible.
- I don't know, I don't give
a (word blanked out) about
trying to make what I
think people will like.
I think because it doesn't
sound like one full album
from top to bottom, people disregard it.
Because it's all over the
place, people think it's messy
or chaotic, but I think
it's beautiful chaos
and it's perfect.
It's my favorite album to date,
regardless of what anyone says.
I could understand why
people don't like it.
It's different, and sometimes different
doesn't equal good to some people.
But I love it and, you know, that's great.
That's all that matters in the end.
If you make something you
a hundred percent love,
and everyone loves it, that's
a (word blanked out) win-win.
That's great.
If you have something that you really love
and everyone (word blanked out) hates it,
at least you (word blanked out) love it,
and you just move on.
- I woke up every morning excited.
I was completely jacked.
I've never been more excited
to go to work every day
as I was on this project.
At the end of the day, I'd
never been more drained
in my life.
But somehow, some way, I
found the energy every morning
to get up and just go for it.
The further we got into it,
the more Wayne was just like,
"Okay, do what you want to
do, do what you want to do."
I never had that kind of freedom before.
- You know, I have tons
of things I'd like to do,
and life is short, unfortunately.
But I hope it will be long enough for me
to do some of these.
I have known a few
writers who have retired.
I cannot imagine ever retiring.
Writing and being a writer is too much
part of my identity, and
too much part of what I am.
I don't know what I would
do with all that time
if I did stop writing, you know.
Play video games or something like that?
Watch a lot more television?
It seem unlikely to me.
I've always told stories, whether I could
make my living from it.
Or even when I was a little
kid just making up stories
for the other kids in the neighborhood.
And I think I'm going to continue
to do that until the end.
- When I talk to pre
first time film makers
or first time film makers,
I always tell them,
"Look, making movies is
eating a sandwich of (word blanked out).
And the only thing that
gets a little better is,
as the years go by, you
get a little more bread.
But the (word blanked out) always there.
- [Interviewer] Isn't
that true of life also?
- I think it is.
I mean, I use another
metaphor for life (laughs).
But for film, I tell you, that one fits.
- [Interviewer] But in the
end, somehow, you find the joy?
- Well, you end up convincing yourself
that it's peanut butter (laughs).
- [Interviewer] And is
it ever peanut butter?
- I want to believe it is (laughs).
- [Interviewer] But do
you look back and go,
"Yes, I did that..."
- I tell you, without a
doubt we may say this,
we may say it's the greatest.
Being an artist in whatever discipline,
dance, painting, theater,
whatever you want,
it's the greatest work on earth.
I mean, it's truly this
hard thing in this way
or that way, but so is every job.
So is every job.
When I was younger, I
worked with my father
on real estate for about five years.
I was the worst car salesman
in the history of car salesmanship.
- [Interviewer] Because
you were too honest?
- Yeah, people would come
and say, "What about this?"
I would say, "no."
(laughs)
I was Glengarry Glen Ross, I
would not get the knife set.
I would be Shelley Levene.
I would be out, out.
It was terrible.
My father said, "You're terrible."
And the other vendors, whenever I went out
the other salesmen, whenever
I went out to a client,
they actually laughed behind my back.
Actually, physically were
laughing behind my back.
And I was the worst.
But in real estate I was good.
I was good in real estate.
My father used to say,
"You have to do this
"to show that you can
have an honest living."
And what I did was work on
real estate in the mornings
and I did monsters in the afternoon.
But I know that when you have a real job,
I painted highways one
summer in Wichita, Kansas.
I mean, a real job has equal heartbreak
and stuff like that, and politics.
- [Interviewer] Well, I mean,
I think it's one of the things
that people really misunderstand,
that as glorious as it is
to be able to do the things
you're passionate about,
and to be an artist,
it's still a job.
- Oh, it's still a job,
yeah, it is, it is.
But God bless anyone that can do this.
It's beautiful and you
have to truly be grateful.
And the only way to remain objective about
how grateful you need to
be, is present your present
to your past self when
you're 20 years old.
And if you go and talk to
yourself at 20 years old
and said, "Would you like
to be doing this movie
"with this budget," what do you think
your response at age 20 would be?
Abso(word blanked out)lutely, yes.
- I knew I wanted to be
in the skating industry.
I love skating too much,
I wanted to be in it.
I didn't know I would make a living
as a professional, but I was
devoted to skateboarding.
So, I refinanced my house
and took all the money
and started a skateboard company,
which seems like the stupidest
thing in the world to do
when skating was dying, but it was
exactly what I wanted to do.
I wanted to be a company owner
and be behind the scenes.
I quit my sponsor and started.
And for about three years,
struggled very hard.
My partner and I, we had
pooled our money together.
He was an ex-pro skater as well.
And we just did Birdhouse and did
whatever we could to get by.
All the team was staying on my couch,
and literally, while I'm changing diapers,
I'm driving guys to these spots
that they're going to get arrested at
because there's no skate parks,
so they're going to go ride school yards.
It was such a strange
existence, but I loved it
because it was skateboarding
and it was exactly what I wanted to do.
And so, we really hunkered down.
I was living on Taco Bell
and peanut butter and jelly
and Top Ramen.
- Mmm.
- Probably three years, for sure.
But I didn't care because I
still got to do what I loved.
That's the thing is that people think,
"Was it a struggle?"
And it's like, well no,
because I loved it too much.
I still got to go skate.
And I had time to skate.
I didn't have to go sit behind
a computer for eight hours
and then hope I get time to skate.
- Mark Twain once said,
"The two most important days
"of your life are the day you were born
"and the day you find out why."
The first of those has
already happened to you
'cause you're sitting right here, kay.
The second, the day that you
find out why you were born
may have already happened to many of you.
And to the others, not yet.
But you will know when it happens.
It will be connected to
something that you truly love.
I've always said to my five sons,
"Choose something that you love to do
"and you'll never work
a day in your life."
- I really love what I'm doing.
Not just so much where people like,
"Oh find your passion and go do it."
A lot of people claim it's
something they really like,
but I enjoy marketing so much,
and creating companies for marketers,
that I work my butt off and
it doesn't seem like work.
I can work 70, 80 hour weeks consistently
and not have to worry about it.
It never stresses me
out, I never feel like,
"Oh, I should take a
vacation," or any of that.
I really do enjoy working.
I'm a workaholic.
- This is my life.
But this is also me livin' it.
You tune in, and what you
should walk away from,
what I would want you
most to walk away with
is the idea of, "Yo, what can I do?
"What am I doing with my life?
"Am I living it or am I just
going to some humdrum job
"that I don't really want to be at,
"doing some minuscule task.
"Getting paid to be a
mindless drone, you know.
"Or am I out there
living life, on my terms,
"the way I want to live it,
"doing the things that I want to do?"
Make no mistake about
it, as hard as this is,
as hard as this is, this
is what I want to do.
This is what I want to do, you know.
And some people can make fun
of it, they can crack jokes,
they can sit back and
analyze and criticize,
and make all the fun they
want, but I'm living my life.
I'm doin' it.
What are you?
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know which of the clips
had the biggest impact on you and why.
Which message resonated with you the most?
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Steph Reveron.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and taking
that picture and posting it.
I really, really, really
appreciate your support.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.